bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre émission en val plaisir infligé
une véritable correction à bâle ii scène
ce dimanche le score est sans appel 41 à
30 leur bilan est désormais de 11
victoires en 12 matches disputés les
détails dans ce magazine football
américain les templiers d'elancourt
débuteront leur saison ce samedi à
domicile contre les gladiateurs de la
cure en bris pour faire le point sur
l'effectif et les ambitions du club nous
recevrons sur ce plateau le président
georges agostino le directeur sportif
predict un show et le running back
alexander song basket l'entente le
chesnay versailles s'est imposée 65 à 50
et original rémy contre sainte claire de
neuilly le nouveau joueur américain de
l'équipe sylvester morgan a brillé
pendant la partie résumer à suivre et
puis l'essentiel de l'actualité sportive
du département nous parlerons notamment
des championnats départementaux de tir à
l'arc qui se sont tenues ce week-end à
trappes
le plaisir handball n'en finit plus de
gagner les yvelinois ont infligé une
véritable correction à val de seine ce
dimanche le score est sans appel 41 à 30
leur bilan est désormais de 11 victoires
en 12 matches disputés conséquence
plaisir est leader de prénationale le
montage a signé à xavier gens on
n'arrête plus le plaisir handball club
les ivy loi se sont imposé une nouvelle
fois à domicile leur victime du jour
val-de-seine largement dominateurs les
plaisirs ont corrigé leurs adversaires
score final 41 30
la consigne s'était pas de prendre le
match à la légère on a bien faire on a
eu on a eu un peu peur au mieux du match
con sen revenue à égalité mais bon là on
a remis les choses au clair
car des gars l'homme du match le gardien
jean marc bérail handballeurs de 41 dont
un sorti une trentaine d'arrêt pendant
la rencontre dont la prix 38 donc j'ai
pas plus satisfait que ça de mon match
avec cette victoire plaisir est premier
du championnat de prénationale labonté
l'objectif fixé cette saison par le club
est donc envisageable
on va parler de montée tout de suite on
va attendre on va prendre les matches
les uns après les autres
il ya paris sportifs qui suit le rythme
est une très très belle équipe
voilà il ya vers 5 est une belle équipe
bien métro la poule est très costaud
donc voilà tous les matches vont être
super important on prend vraiment
personne à la légère et on verra on fera
les comptes au mois de juin en espérant
que cette fois ça par pur plaisir
prochain match pour plaisir ce dimanche
7 février contre evry une équipe qui
lutte pour le dentier
on ouvre à présent une page football
américain les templiers d'elancourt
débuteront leur saison dans le
championnat élite ce samedi à domicile
contre les gladiateurs de la
queue-en-brie pour nous parler de la
saison des templiers et des objectifs
nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président georges agostino le directeur
sportif fredy k painchaud et le running
back des templiers avec son offre saas
ont surnommé le prophète
bonsoir messieurs alors les templiers
sont ils prêts à l'aube de cette
nouvelle saison
georges que oui je pense tout le monde a
appris à travailler pour préparer cette
nouvelle saison 4 on pense frédéric que
les coaches ont super bien travaillé les
joueurs sont hypermotivés je pense qu on
a tout pour tous les ingrédients sont
réunis pour cette nouvelle saison les
ingrédients sont réunis il faut savoir
qu'on repart d'une saison saison pas
blanche une saison difficile l'année
dernière donc on a tout reconstruit on a
tourné lite on a un air porte ton a
changé quatre coaches sur cinq n'a
changé de façon de travailler
donc effectivement les joueurs
travaillent depuis le mois de septembre
et je pense efficacement maintenant on
veut voir c'est la réalité du terrain
on la verra samedi soir alexander la
tactique la technique tout y est pour
cette nouvelle saison je pense que sur
cette saison là on est beaucoup mieux
préparé que les autres que les saisons
passées
on a un nouveau un nouveau coach sportif
voilà qu'après qui a fait toute notre
préparation donc hivernale et je pense
qu'on est bientôt fin je pense qu'on est
déjà prêt pour le premier match qui
arrive donc ce samedi-là 100% prêt
physiquement également exercice
mentalement je pense que tout ira bien
autre côté vous avez de grandes
ambitions georges pour cette nouvelle
saison quels sont les objectifs du coup
de north les objectifs on va faire du
mieux possible
la fameuse langue de bois lors nettement
voilà il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de changements quelques
tournois verts dans les joueurs essaient
de faire
- bien évidemment ça serait très bien
d'approché d'être dans les milieu de
classement pour pouvoir avoir au visu
les playoffs mais voilà comme dee
alexander on a fait rire les joueurs ont
fait une superbe opération les coaches
sont investis à fond tous les joueurs
sont là maintenant il ya toujours un
doute du terrain on va voir samedi
pour l'instant j'attends avec impatience
au dos premier match pour me faire une
petite idée de la saison qui nous attend
avec par shaw un titre cette saison
c'est possible selon vous chaque année
c'est possible chaque année un titre est
possible après c'est la réalité du
terrain qui la donne c'est le nombre de
blessés qu'on peut avoir c'est s'est
plaint de ses pleins de petits détails
qui font que ba une saison commence bien
où commence pas très très bien donc on
verra bien on va prendre match après
match on va y aller patiemment et et
puis peu à peu on l'appétit viendra en
mangeant pour être en adéquation avec
vos objectifs vous avez recruté un
nouveau jour en provenance de sacramento
jay hill était au micro de floral
parfait très content pour les saisons
et je crois que nous nous allons
garnier champigny et e
je promets je promets nous allons gagner
les championnats georges juive le titre
dès cette année 1 comme tout bon america
qui se respecte ils sont toujours à fond
à 110% donc j'espère que nous allons à
raison fois que nous on lui donne raison
il ya une anecdote assez particulière
sur ce joueur vous l'avez par hasard
djédjé n'est pas un import comme on a
classiquement l'habitude d'aller
chercher c'est à dire d'aller aux états
unis ou en fait j'ai été déjà en france
et il est dans une famille il est au
pair dans une famille et il était là
depuis mois d'août et c'est il avait
envie de reprendre le sport il n'allait
pas se passe très bien et avec le
monsieur qu'il qu'il fait travailler
il a fait le tour de pratiquement tous
les clubs en ile de france et il a été
regardé à droite à gauche en fait quand
il est arrivé aux templiers
il a trouvé qu'il y avait des structures
que c'était assez les pros que c'était
assez sérieux et donc il a signé chez
nous alors il a regardé au départ et
puis il a signé au début on ne savait
pas qui c'était puis quand on a tapé son
nom sur google on a vu qui c'était
ou est-ce qu'il avait joué on était
assez contente donc un sacré morceau
c'est un sacré morceau cela un joueur
qui a joué au plus haut niveau
universitaire avec des pics dans des
stades de 70 80 mille personnes qui
connaît qui connaît football aime rien
il n'a pas joué depuis cinq ans il est
comme il n'avait pas joué depuis cinq
ans mais il a vraiment du talent c'est
vraiment un très très très bon joueur et
comme tout joueur américain comme dit
notre président ce sont des gens qui
viennent pour gagner ils viennent pas
uniquement pour jouer ils viennent pour
gagner c'est l'heure c'est vrai que
motive alexander vous êtes d'accord avec
flights et c'est un vrai bon joueur ans
et j'ai franchement c'est un vrai bon
joueur je pense vraiment que ce sera
l'une des clés de notre succès
cette année ce sera dès maintenant
personne ne nous attend aujourd'hui dans
le championnat je pense avec la saison
qu'on a fait l'année dernière et je
pense justement car personne nous attend
on a notre chance vraiment de d'amener
cet effet de surprise
surtout avec ce nouveau joueur est à
voir avec notre préparation comme j'ai
déjà dit on devrait faire quelque chose
d'intéressant ne survienne autre
changement notable pour les templiers
cette année pas de coiffeur bac 100%
américain johnatan et qui mène ce sera
la tête d'affiché à ce poste pourquoi
avoir choisir du coup un joueur non
américain 100% voilà ce qui était quand
même un petit peu amérique là où il est
un petit peu américain mais bon il est
français c'est un quarterback non c'est
pas parce qu'on est parti dans notre
projet le nouveau projet qu'on s'est
fixés c'est de faire de la formation
en prenant des jeunes issus de notre
club d'autres clubs mais qui viennent
chez nous pour jouer à la place de
quarterback c'est un poste très
compliqué généralement la plupart des
clubs en france et en europe vont
chercher des quarterbacks américain
puisqu'on sait que l'alors valeurs et
tout est très bonne mais voilà nous on a
décidé de se lancer dans ce projet de
former des quarterbacks français chez
nous et donc on va comment comment dire
johnattan a déjà écumé or la saison lors
de la saison de division 2 lorsque nous
étions remontés c'est lui qui a permis
la remontée en division élite
donc il connaît la maison il connaît
parfaitement la maison il connaît le job
est derrière lui
il ya on a recruté un jeune quarterback
français prêt à le suppléer mais faudra
qu'il se prépare correctement parce que
jonathan ne laissera pas sa place comme
ça on écoute justement il était au micro
de florennes parfait je vais essayer
d'être un leader à un exemple pour
chacun et je vais essayer d'organiser
l'équipe et de donner le meilleur de moi
même à chaque match alexander vous qu'il
côtoyait également l'entraînement
c'est un vrai bon joueur c'est un vrai
bon joueur il a toutes les qualités de
deux quarterbacks peu mais également
joué le receveur et je pense que sa
valeur ajoutée dans le championnat et
voilà tout le championnat il connaît
déjà
je pense qu'avec lui on peut gagner un
titre ok connu tous les quarterbacks y
sont passés
comparé par les templiers où se situer
comment du coup ce jeu de la table par
contre si je devrais situer par rapport
aux autres bacs on a déjà eu qu'on a
déjà été présent les 6 si je devais le
mettre dans une catégorie je le mets ta
troisième derrière vie numérote et sean
chen vraiment après les excellents mais
les deux quarterbacks on a eu le dernier
les deux derniers concerts bacs
américains ont eu vraiment une grosse
valeur ajoutée dans le championnat
français et d'orge
on voit qu'il ya une véritable volonté
de former chez vous aux templiers cette
année vous et une volonté mûrement
réfléchie ou c'est peut-être un choix
par défaut financiers c'est un vrai
choix un nounou bien sûr on l'a toujours
été
les tourbillons toujours
accès la formation est une des priorités
du club soucis avec les cadets l'année
dernière changement de catégorie et
autres là avec fred
c'était la volonté de relancer les u16
pour l'instant ça va très bien un match
une victoire
les juniors deux matches deux victoires
ils viennent de battre orléans chez eux
samedi soir dernier donc tout va bien au
niveau jeunes on espère que la réserve a
emboîté le pas et on espère que l'élite
voisins pourraient tout ça et tout ira
plus mûrs du monde
les u16 les u19 ils doivent alimenter
l'équipe première c'est là l'objectif
c'est la base c'est la base c'est inouï
16 deviennent de bons u19 et que notre
nos u19 alimente soit l'équipe b mais
surtout l'équipe élite
l'idée c'est que l'on ne perde de moins
en moins de joueurs dans ces catégories
qui se retourne vers d'autres sports
c'est là qu'il reste au football
américain qui deviennent vraie valeur
ajoutée
un joueur qui aura cinq six ans de
football américain derrière lui sera une
vraie valeur ajoutée pour l'équipe élite
des templiers
en février dernier le club a organisé
une conférence de presse avec notamment
la présentation des nouveaux maillots
nouveau maillot qu'on va justement ici
il ya un directeur sportif qui vient
d'arriver
voilà montrer le bien la caméra voilà un
directeur sportif du coach lyonnais vit
avec vous ferez lettres painchaud il ya
également les u16 qui renaît qui sont
qui sont voilà de nouveau compétitive
cette saison qui avait disparu pendant
un an on a l'impression qu'il ya
vraiment une volonté de
professionnaliser club de faire entrer
le club dans une nouvelle ère vous avez
ce sentiment là aussi georges
c'est l'objectif tous les clubs de
france là chaque année sa franche et une
marche aux deux roues on est vraiment
obligé de suivre
le système marche et il faut se remettre
en question à année après année c'était
le cas cette année pas mal de
bouleversements
on espère que tout ça sera positif et à
porteur de bonnes nouvelles est plein de
victoires mais oui il faut tous les ans
il faut il faut gravir une marche
supplémentaire parce que les autres
clubs faut pas oublier quand on joue
contre des grandes métropoles françaises
nice nice on va dire qu'est-ce qui me
dit qu'il ne sera pas ex fc thoune
al-balah exemple la courneuve bon nous
et le cours saint quentin 118 on est un
petit peu petit par rapport à tout cela
donc à chaque fois on est obligé de
batailler en objet de faire le miracle
de plus de trouver des solutions auprès
des jeunes les vraiment obligé c'est un
amalgame de tout ça qui fait que le club
est toujours là et toujours positionnés
en élite et on espère le rester dans les
prochaines années
mais on est poussé même si on veut pas
on est obligé de se mettre en cause tous
les ans et doit partir enfin les
pensions il ya eu un déclic
il ya une prise de conscience france
réelle pendant l'intersaison où l'alsace
c'est vrai comme designer alexander la
saison dernière a été compliquée a été
très très compliquée du multiples
facteurs et je pense qu'il est les gens
ont pris conscience que le club des
templiers pouvait pas se satisfaire
d'une vie monotone et là en servant
voilà on s'est retroussé les manches
beaucoup de gens se sont avait des idées
et en a en essayent de professionnaliser
de rendre un petit peu plus
professionnel ce club et pour rang pour
pourquoi pas un jour lutter avec les
meilleurs clubs européens
pour ça il faut il faut il faut
travailler il faut travailler on y va
patiemment ont construit doucement
inutile de sprinter on est un sport
d'endurance pour l'instant donc il ya ce
premier match ce week-end contre les
gladiateurs d'accueil en brie vous allez
partir favori sur cette rencontre
un petit pronostique alexander normes
normalement on est censé partir favori
voilà ils viennent de monter en première
division et pour nous ce serait vraiment
enfin on voit pas là
on n'a pas comme solution de perdre
c'est pas possible on doit pas perdre ce
match de ce premier match et voilà après
je pense qu'on serait plutôt normalement
devrait on aurait à dire un gros score
pour ce prime alors un petit pronostic
1,6060 0 la pression mais la raison
qu'il reste à la création d'avoir des
joueurs à avoir des joueurs qui est un
comble ambition c'est ça c'est le plus
important on aux deux coaches
coordinateur michael marion et frederick
henderson demande à ce que les joueurs
aient de l'ambition
moi j'appelle ça des ambitions
raisonnables voilà ils viennent de
division 2 certes on les respecte
énormément mais mais voilà ils sont chez
nous et puis et puis voilà les templiers
tant qu'ils sont là et et on a envie de
leur montrer que la division élite c'est
pas la division 2 c'est pas c'est pas
tranquille voilà donc 70 euros je fais
un petit peu plus raisonnables inter
jean charles dans le projet s'agit du
record j'ai récemment un très très bon
score favorable et ne marquera les
esprits et permettra à l'équipe de se
projeter leur merci à tous les toits
d'être passé sur ce passé c'était un
plaisir de vous recevoir bon courage
pour ce premier match de la saison
je le rappelle ce match est programmé le
samedi à 20 heures au complexe sportif
europe on passe à présent au basket
l'entente le chesnay-versailles
s'offrent une bouffée d'oxygène les
yvelinois englué dans le bas du
classement d'excellence se sont imposés
65 à 51 au gymnase tr min contre siens
saint-pierre de neuilly nouveaux joueurs
américains de l'équipe sylvester morgan
a brillé pendant la partie camille
lambert pour les images le chesnay
versailles a réalisé la bonne opération
de cette 12e journée du championnat
excellence les elvinois se rapproche du
podium après avoir dominé saint pierre
de nolhac domicile 65 à 50 et je pense
qu'on a été plus régulier dans le jeu de
nos adversaires on avait on avait
clairement une force en plus dans la
raquette qu'il n'avait pas pourtant ils
ont quand même je trouve très bien ils
s'en sont très bien sortis nous ont
quand même posé des problèmes
mais l' équilibre le fait françois non
oui on a on a été je pense plus sérieux
que l'on mérite on mérite amplement
d'être victoire une victoire acquise
grâce aux 18 points de sylvester morgan
le pivot américain de 2,06 à intégrer
l'équipe à la mi janvier
le basketteur a notamment joué dans le
championnat universitaire aux états unis
après un premier match compliqué le
joueur monte en puissance
je pense que je m'améliore la dernière
fois j'ai marqué des tirs à l'intérieur
là j'ai amélioré mes tirs à l'extérieur
c'est vraiment positif pour la suite
puisque les points ils apportent les
rebonds la présence défensive que le
fétiche qui poussent les joueurs qui
l'encouragé c'est tout un ensemble de
choses qui fait que la ce a permis au
groupe de badauds gagner de montagne le
prochain match pour sylvester et ses
nouveaux coéquipiers le samedi 6 février
sur le terrain de melun après le basket
en focus sur un autre sport américain a
le baseball avec les cougars de montier
breteuil on continue donc ce magazine
par du baseball les cougars de montils
bretons ne sont devenus en 2015 le plus
grand club de france avec 2 155
licenciés
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur en
compte douze mille licenciés en france
pour nous parler de cette réussite nous
recevons un écoutons la présidente ainsi
qu'odile anne mahieu coach adjoint de
l'équipe senior bonsoir alors comment
expliquez vous cette réussite à nos
moutons le baseball se développe de plus
en plus en france donc à montigny nous
avons une grande visibilité un peu grâce
à vous aussi et puis aussi par d'autres
stades qui est située au milieu de la
ville dont beaucoup de gens nous voient
et beaucoup de gens sont tentés depuis
deux ans nous faisons aussi des
interventions dans les écoles donc ce
qui a peut-être aussi incité des enfants
à venir nous voir et nous avons une
recrudescence de seniors aussi je ne
sais pas pourquoi donc tant mieux pour
nous il ya une véritable culture
baseball dans les yvelines
oh oui vous l'avez ce création à mesure
des années le nom il ya une véritable
culture baseball dans les yvelines
puisque dans les yvelines nous avons
quand même aussi un autre grand club
un nom la bretèche saint-germain là
aussi puis nous avons aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup d'américains qui vivent sur les
yvelines beaucoup de japonais comme pour
eux ce sont quand même leurs sports
nationaux ils sont intéressés à venir
jouer dans nos clubs
ce sport intéresse aussi bien les filles
que les garçons enfin pour les fils et
le softball mais est-ce que ça intéresse
également les filles le baseball on m'a
quand même beaucoup moins de licenciés
filles cette année mais on a quand même
on compte quand même quatre filles en
moins de 15 ans plusieurs plusieurs
petites en moins de 9 ans et il me
semble une petite en moins de 12 ans des
événements comme la venue de megan
moulis il ya quelques semaines la star
du softball aux états unis peut
également influer justement sur sur la
renommée la réputation de ce sport au 8
août face aux puces c'est un plus oui ça
a été un plus et ça a fait venir des
amateurs de softball de tout tout le
nord de la france sont venus à montigny
pour participer à ces ateliers
donc c'est vrai que ça a été un plus
pour le développement du soft paul un
vrai plus
les gens vous en vous en avons parlé les
amateurs oui mais ça n'a pas été
suffisamment médiatisé pour que les ceux
qui n'ont pas la connaissance du
softball puisse y venir et les jeunes
qui ont participé à ces ateliers les
jeunes ont été en usage former les
jeunes ritter sourire la fin de la
journée ils avaient le sourire et puis
il y avait là il avait l'impression
d'avoir que rencontrer quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire votre fanion votre
équipe fanion reste l'équipe une les
seniors qui évolue en deuxième division
l'objectif sera de monter cette année je
vais laisser dylan répondre ilan
oui donc cette année on a on a
l'objectif de monter on a je pense un
bon effectif des retours de d'ancien
joueur avec un gros potentiel qui peut
nous monter pour l'année prochaine et
votre effectif justement on vous en
parlait l'effectif est composé de deux
nouveaux joueurs ils se sont bien
intégrés dans l'équipe
oui on a une bonne ambiance dans
l'équipe sur le terrain c'est pareil on
s'entend bien on a
normalement un américain qui devrait
venir milieu du mois de mars il me
semble et ensuite on a le retour des
anciens joueurs qui évoluent en élite
avant et je pense que ça peut être une
bonne saison l'effectif est de qualité
cette saison continue de qualité c'est
peut-être l'une des meilleures équipes
que vous ayez eu ces dernières saisons
vous pensez je ne sais pas faudra la
voir à l'oeuvre le premier match dans la
verra à l'oeuvre pendant les matches de
préparation puisque nous avons tout le
mois de mars nous avons prévu de faire
des matches de préparation dans un une
journée enfin un week-end qui sera assez
lourd pour eux puisqu'ils vont partir à
montpellier et qui est affronté les et
l'équipe une de montpellier une équipe
qui évolue en élite et qui a été
finaliste du championnat de france d1
donc là on va voir qu'est ce que cette
équipe a dans les tripes
vous avez en tout cas les moyens de vos
ambitions cette année on s'est donné les
moyens de nos ambitions après faudra
prendre les matches les uns derrière les
autres
vous avez entamé une bonne préparation
de saison oui les entraînements on est
on est bien régulier au niveau des
entraînements contrairement un petit peu
aux autres années où c'était pas trop
pas trop ça et là cette année on sent
tous déjà après deux mois de la saison
et votre votre fils alexandre coton sera
une nouvelle fois le coach oui à
l'équipe on sera encore le coach de
l'équipe de l'équipe une puisqu'il en a
on lui a demandé l'a souhaité le rester
donc je pense qu'il a il est connu de
nombreux joueurs donc je pense qu'il a
aussi il a la confiance d'un certain
nombre de joueurs donc et le club lui
donne sa confiance donc nous espérons
qu'il atteindra les objectifs que nous
lui avons fixés et qu'il s'est fixé
lui-même d'ailleurs parce qu'il jouera
également
je ne sais pas faut voir avec dylan
jouera là on a pour objectif de vraiment
se concentrer sur le niveau de jeu
réussir un petit peu avant les matchs se
concentrer sur le niveau coaching pour
pouvoir mélanger les deux sur le terrain
donc vous êtes dans la poule des riders
dessine des boucaniers de la rochelle de
l'équipe fédérale de toulouse et les
deux filles de deux cents juste est ce
que vous êtes favoris selon vous dis là
mais pour moi on est réponse est
finalement un petit peu sont pas très
connus un parent voilà donc on ne sait
pas ce que ce que vaut l'équipe adverse
sans jamais rencontrer on n'a jamais vu
jouer sur un terrain donc on ne peut pas
se prononcer favori maintenant je sais
que avec le groupe qu'on a on a vraiment
moyen de faire quelque chose pendant la
saison on vous le souhaite en tout cas
merci à tous d'être passé sur ce plateau
donc on vous souhaite bon courage
je vous rappelle que la saison débute en
avril on passe maintenant au tir à l'arc
après une large page sports américains
les archers yvelinois avait coché cette
date dans leur calendrier depuis
plusieurs mois les championnats
départementaux étaient programmées tout
au long du week-end au gymnase de youri
gagarine attrape les 300 meilleurs
archers aide des yvelines se sont
affrontés à cette occasion le montage
est signée xavier gens de la
concentration du sang froid et de la
précision des ingrédients indispensables
pour viser la victoire pendant les
championnats départementaux de tir à
l'arc pour la 13ème année consécutive la
compétition était organisée ce week-end
au gymnase jury gagarine attrape
aujourd'hui se bat surtout pour le titre
de champion départemental puisque en
fait les qualifications se font sur les
compétitions qui ont lieu depuis le mois
d'octobre jusqu'à maintenant et on prend
les trois meilleurs scores de
de cet ensemble de compétitions pour
cette épreuve trois cents archers venus
d'une vingtaine de clubs des villes ont
fait le déplacement
il ya des gens qui ont un très bon
niveau et qui cherche les qualifications
pour le championnat régional ou de
championnat de france et puis il y en a
qui ont un niveau intermédiaire et qui
viennent plus pour s'amuser pour passer
une bonne journée avec les amis
départements qui sont prises donc
forcément c'est bah ça élève le niveau
et ouais voilà ça nous permet aussi de
nous comparer de voir à peu près où on
est classé enfin franchement c'est super
intéressant d'en faire dans la catégorie
cadet arc classique homme richard
thibault de manila avoir remporté la
compétition chez les dames margot des
grippes de maurepas a terminé sur la
plus haute marche du podium dans la
catégorie junior on passe maintenant aux
autres résultats du week end
on commence cette rubrique résultats par
du rugby une victoire de plus pour
plaisir en fédérale 3 les joueurs
coachés par jean miss on s'est très
facilement battu caen sur leur terrain
lors de la 12e journée du championnat
le score est sans appel 33,3 avec cinq
essais à la clé une défense de fer au
classement plaisir est donc premier à
égalité de points avec ris orangis et
peut toujours espérer accrocher la
montée en fédérale 2 on écoute
l'entraîneur adjoint du rugby-club de
plaisir phone avec jardin il était
évidemment ravi de la performance de ses
joueurs bonne prestation des joueurs on
les avait mis en
on les avait mis en garde parce que
c'est une équipe qui était difficile à
manier on le savait une équipe qui
revenaient une équipe qui revient de
très loin puisque c'est une équipe qui
sera construite au fil de l'année est
très satisfait de la prestation de mes
joueurs aujourd'hui
le but en est jamais facile
les infos qu'on m'avait donné aux
joueurs d'être rigoureux des deux
patients ont payé puisque on marque sur
plusieurs phases de jeu lancement porter
quelque chose qu'on leur avait demandé
d'être rigoureux on reste dans le rugby
mais cette fois ci en première série
c'est à dire quatre divisions en dessous
de plaisir les montants réussi un
incroyable exploit en remportant la
victoire sur le score de écoutez moi
bien 109 à 0 contre pantin l'extérieur
un score très rare dans le rugby au
classement montigny le bretonneux reste
troisième à 13 points de la première
place détenue par mail sur marne une
marche mythique était programmé ce
week-end je veux bien sûr parler de
paris mantes cette année la compétition
fêter sa 81ème édition plus de 1000
marcheurs se sont élancés dans le froid
et sous la pluie de la place d'un mal de
versailles samedi à minuit pour
rejoindre mantes la jolie en passant par
ben maul et juno et du mobile
54 kilomètres étaient au programme de la
randonnée nocturne patrick cher en si
l'organisateur du pari menthe 2016 était
au micro de camille lambert
ce sont des sportifs des férus de reuben
de randonnée puis qui attendent ça tous
les ans avec impatience un ça vient
aussi de tout
de toute la france et même maintenant
nous avons des étrangers de landes
d'angleterre de belgique qui viennent
participer à cette marche qui est
certainement une des seules marche de
nuit l'autre et ça aussi le qui fait le
charme de cette randonnée les meilleurs
marcheurs ont terminé la course à six
heures du matin avec une vitesse moyenne
de 9 km heure on termine par de la boxe
boxing club de la verrière remporté
quatre titres à l'occasion du
championnat régional d'île de france
minimes qui se déroule à corbeil
essonnes ce week end
parmi les principaux résultats khemiri
pont est devenu champion d'île de france
sont à catégorie des moins de 57 kg il
est donc qualifié pour le championnat
inter régional s'habille lui qui est
elle devenue vice championne
d'ile-de-france après avoir échoué en
finale
c'est la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78